[Musique]
je connais thomas sankara toit
pourra tester sur descendons
mais j'y vais pas faire des amis tous
ces personnes à un président qui n'a pas
sur nous voilà vous êtes là avec la cité
lévis bon c'est bien je vois leur usine
avec ses biens cousine à lévis mais ça
c'est américain wayne mc à makamba san
francisco c'était cuit san francisco
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse du
malheur de bien connaître je connais pas
bien je vais pas te mentir mais en tout
cas chez que c'est un grand homme parce
qu'on a vu que l'on connaît tous son
prénom c'est qu'il a marqué 10 points et
je reconnais qu'à lâche criminel ils s'y
prennent mal
mais ça ça veut dire quoi c'est la
révolution petite bourgeoise devenu
bougea sont comme ça il saisit tout le
temps ils sont pauvres en théorie nul en
pratique alors j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
part d'élus à l'école oui j'ai passé
déjà on
à part l esclavage s'arrête à la sur
l'histoire des noirs c'est tout ce qu'on
connaît personnellement de l'école ce
que j'ai appris à l'école j'ai entendu
parler de l'escalavage après pour
hambourg moi je suis un rappeur oui
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a vraiment
inspirée
dans la musique même dans mon discours
pour ça les gars renseignez vous c'est
important vous faire vivre sa mémoire
connaissances vous à bientôt
l'impérialisme les mauvaises élèves
découverte professeur la patrie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme malade en avant pour la libération
de l'afrique la patrie ou la mort nous
vaincrons moi ce que j'aime bien dans
thomas sankara c'est son verbe laver des
punchline comme on dit
thomas sankara ça rime avec fierté et
dignité en fait
[Musique]
ce genre de personnage il passe une fois
tous les cent ans la forme est une forme
révolutionnaire authentique moi de
réussir leurs défunts de la femme coûte
que coûte on avait un modèle parfait de
féminisme qui s'y met on dit que la
façon
dont on a forcément des ennemis et ils
sont nombreux ces ennemis c'est d'abord
le capitalisme internationaux sans gaz
qui dit bien ce qu'on s'ennuie pas quoi
et c'est pas la politique nous faut qu
d'appuyer là où ça fait mal digne d'un
roman scène d'un film tu vois c'est
hollywood presque
[Musique]
la patrie ou la mort nous vaincrons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
in nuit
au cap à ma porte je me lève je vais
ouvrir cette commission créée blaise
compaore qui sont arrêtés ils sont venus
à pied
je les reçois donc si ma terrasse comme
ça
et puis il me dit
on va prendre le pouvoir on va
transformer les choses dans ce pays
j'ai dit ah
cette nuit là la cia qui est très jeune
qui va réunir ses forces
[Musique]
il va prendre le pouvoir et qui va
constituer une équipe de jeunes
incorruptibles ont révolutionné son pays
[Musique]
allait dans le goût de stanford blaise
[Rires]
avec ses compagnons qui te plaisent
compaoré il faut préparer du coup d'état
plestan théorique était enfin résolue
aussi mais que tu es plus l'ombre de
l'ombre qui était plus introverti qui
parlait pas beaucoup mais dont on disait
qu'il était tout aussi déterminé que
thomas sankara
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que je voulais avec cette image du
militaire
frêle très déterminé dans le ton et le
regard
qui a pris la parole pour annoncer
qu'aujourd'hui 4 août 1983 on instaurait
la révolution
[Applaudissements]
il faut alterner
tous les ennemis du peuple
il faut enterrer
tous les vols qui empêche le peuple de
se libérer c'est le peuple dans tout le
pays c'est pas tant d'autres la
révolution c'est pas un dîner de gala
c'est pas avec des queues de pie ix et
des papillons ont fait la révolution
préparation les voleurs les fraudeurs
c'est un bouleversement youtube qui
amène une classe politique pouvoir
politique
c'est limpide c'est clair il a fait son
choix et les deux côtés des peuples
laver son plan tête voulait charger son
pays
si on est tellement dans l'évolution du
poids
[Applaudissements]
les jeunes ont tout de suite épuisé ce
mouvement et l'ont pris à rend le port
tout de suite envahi la rue l'ont clamé
et se sont proposés sans attendre qu'on
les appelle
en afrique jamais à pouvoir ne s'appuie
sur la jeunesse tous les dirigeants du
pays ont une trentaine d'années ce qui
ne se reproduira plus jamais jusqu'à
maintenant
[Musique]
donner des responsabilités à ces jeunes
c'est une explosion d'énergie qui à tout
point de vue
[Musique]
le pantin de 100 kg tellement fait ça à
des milliers de fois que je me souviens
de chaque détail de son visage les yeux
le nez les oreilles si tout le bella qui
est l'élément important
c'est clair qu'au niveau d'éclairement
et luthier de sankara réclamant
révolutionnaire nous avons clairement
artiste engagé c'est pour ça que nous
prenons les risques de matérialiser son
visage parce que il n'ya pas longtemps
on pourrait pas le faire
tu as ce qu'il a écrit
défense d'oublier les petits
on n'a pas le droit d'oublier cette aune
la patrie ou la mort nous on veut penser
l'une des phrases quand on finit de
laïcité on a l'impression est une
énergie qui paraissent le coin
aujourd'hui on n'a pas un autre ip
sankara il est plus que jamais présent
dans l'esprit de la jeunesse africaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez
ça c'est américain voit même ses seins
mccabe à san francisco
pour y arriver il a été à la tête de
mesures radicales et de prises de
position avant-gardiste pour l'époque
s'identifient à une icône c'est super
important
moi je sais que ma perception des choses
elle a changé quand j'ai quand je me
suis intéressé à sankara tous les noirs
un moment donné il se pose la question
de fond vient qui sont nos héros où est
ce qu'on va comment on peut arranger les
choses à un moment donné tous les noirs
se pose cette question en tout cas en
france
[Musique]